desplazamientos forzados abusos sexuales
torturas o matanzas la violencia contra
la población civil se recrudece en
afganistán a medida que avanza la
insurgencia talibán que ha generado una
crisis humanitaria y un éxodo masivo
hacia la capital kabul y otras regiones
todavía bajo el control gubernamental
desde mayo al menos 200 civiles han sido
asesinados y otros miles fueron heridos
naciones unidas- de alarma de graves
violaciones de derechos humanos contra
los civiles distinguen la ley islámica
impuesta por los talibanes
hitler de de interior edwin a gente vive
con miedo y temor ya las mujeres ya
están siendo sometidas y tiroteadas por
infringir las normas que han impuesto
sobre lo que pueden llevar y por donde
pueden circular sin escolta masculinos
corrí
en las ciudades que ya han sido tomadas
por el talibán y en las áreas en disputa
las oficinas han estado recibiendo
reportes de ejecuciones ataques contra
funcionarios y ex funcionarios del
gobierno y sus familias militares y de
destrucción de hogares escuelas y
clínicas
y la instalación de minas y explosivos
improvisados países si bien millones de
personas de las zonas rurales han
sobrevivido durante años bajo las normas
del yugo talibán los islamistas están
tomando ahora el control de las grandes
urbes ya sus siete capitales de
provincia que han caído en sus manos
ante la imposibilidad de las fuerzas de
seguridad afganas de repeler sus ataques
con millones de civiles atrapados en el
intercambio de artillería la ayuda
humanitaria es castell a pesar los
pedidos de auxilio de las autoridades
afganas
la gente no puede llegar a los servicios
de salud o esto no funciona normalmente
debido a los daños oa la imposibilidad
de desplazarse porque el personal no
puede trabajar no puede acceder a las
clínicas o porque los hospitales están
en medio de la línea de 33
klein la velocidad vertiginosa con la
que los talibanes han acumulado
victorias en el campo de batalla desde
el anuncio de la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses y sus aliados de suelo
afgano vislumbra un trágico destino para
la población civil